hello you are registering the harrow
the information that I gave you and
capital so stop everything number one
solid hope is that you have chosen
even a few days before or after we
talk about it but it is absolutely necessary
to hold the pay even chaired with
which you  are registered i.e.
if you register capa evening there to
bring your passport if you arrive
with a jacket the entity other than the one
with which you are registered you
will not be eligible for a refund or
a report
if you have a  problem with 2.9 t it
was stolen because you eat by a full
contact and nick immediately attention
the oral test is not necessarily the same
day as the written test that it can take
place a few days before or after when
you receive your invitation  note
the goods put possibilities everywhere
tell your mother because the oral is
neither modifiable nor refundable number 4
if you have not received your
summons within 15 ver.  ify your
spam junk mail finally
you call it what you want number 5
if it's not in
junk mail or more can call it
like all other assets
i.e. you condemn us
number 6 if  you are under 18
we need the consent of their
parents have left the premises we can
go up to a year without the protection
of minors there is no longer drinking water
in france so yes if you are 17
you  are still not considered
lower danube from our premises
you need parental permission
put your pride aside have
the letter signed and we'll let you go
number 7 plan your journey imagine
you have a plane to bora bora d  one
of the demonstrations their hours of walking not
you have to do everything for amateurs have
spent the jubilation you need the same
determination so plan your trip
there are always unforeseen events number 8
be on time your info will offer
bora and  dad wait for you so if you
are late for lines
unfortunately you won't be a
myth number 9 only led your
id don't need data
with your purse auchan
roncq just came with your id  and
we will provide you with everything else
latham the chain of pens you have to
return to lead the om but the
bottle must be transparent if you
follow your experience
elsewhere this time it will be an email and you
will arrive safely
[Music]